during the summer of 2022 major flooding
across the u.s displaced hundreds of
people swept away buildings and claimed
more than 50 lives
this is
unbelievable
you have multiple factors that are
playing together that are kind of
capitalizing and producing some of these
dramatic flash flooding events that
we've seen
dr jonathan gourley who studies how to
predict flash floods says a combination
of outdated infrastructure extreme
weather events and a backdrop of warming
temperatures contributed to these floods
and research indicates they could be
getting worse
most of the time the way that flash
floods occur is from heavy rainfall
that's occurring from above
flash flooding can appear within hours
sometimes even minutes of a rainstorm
large volumes of water fall quickly and
can flow downhill into a stream or river
the river rises and overflows its banks
as a result the flood water moves
swiftly and in populated areas can take
residents by surprise trapping people in
homes or other buildings
large debris like cars and trees can
also be swept into the flow posing
additional danger
in urban settings the fast-moving water
can overwhelm some infrastructure
because we have a large urban footprint
over cities like las vegas they're
simply not able to handle the incoming
rainfall in the storm sewer system the
soils there have been covered by
concrete and asphalt and so that causes
the water to basically turn in into
runoff immediately whenever the water
does become runoff it also moves very
quickly
areas in the u.s where wildfires have
killed vegetation are also more likely
to experience flash floods the soils
there don't permit as much infiltration
as they normally would there's less
uptake by the vegetation and that can
cause big problems with severe erosion
flash floods and they can even cause a
debris flow
some cities have implemented green
infrastructure projects that could help
mitigate flooding philadelphia and
portland oregon have used porous
pavement which allows water to pass
through and new york offers funding for
green roofs where vegetation can help
reduce and slow storm water runoff
since 1901 the average annual
precipitation in the contiguous 48
states has increased at a rate of
two-tenths of an inch per decade and in
2021 more than 18 percent of u.s land
area experienced extremes in intense
single-day precipitation events
a peer-reviewed study by dr gourley and
other scientists found that if
greenhouse gas emissions remain high
earth's warming climate could cause
flash floods to become nearly eight
percent more extreme by the end of the
century
that's in part because warmer air holds
more water
for instance the same volume of air can
hold around twice as much water vapor at
70 degrees fahrenheit as it can at 50
degrees so whenever we have a mechanism
to
move that air up and it begins to cool
and that sets into motion the rainfall
that's going to ultimately result in the
flash floods
flash floods cause 2.4 billion dollars
in property damage and killed 135 people
in the u.s in 2021 second only to
fatalities related to extreme heat
according to the national weather
service most flooding deaths from 2011
to 2021 happened to people while driving
unless we adapt to our cities and adapt
our ways of moving around in our
infrastructure and everything then we
would anticipate there being more
fatalities from flash flooding and
property damage
[Music]
you